je me demande s'ils empruntent ou
surestimé le nombre de pizzas manger
sain que c'était une par terre ça c'est
ce que personne
[Musique]
c'est une grosse journée qui débute
aussi mon rôle un peu stressante
aujourd'hui je vais au pop up store je
vous emmène avec moi up store de deux
voix de plus pour lancement de 20 de
plus cette pro fnac des ternes on est
entre autres y en a d'autres que je
connais pas avec jérôme de nos textes et
vit avec quentin moi même c'est toute la
journée à rencontrer les fans de la
marque weight plus qu'ils sont venus
pour voir le aux produits et aussi pour
venir nous voir donc on va se rencontrer
un mode histoire pas si facilement tant
sens où c'est vraiment génial je suis
hyper excitées notre côté un peu de
stress mais je pense que ça va être une
expérience incroyable vous avez d'être
refoulé
[Musique]
je suis explosé
tu peux pas dire ça j'étais à lire sur
deux masseurs d'entendre la france donc
du coup je me lavais de remonter toutes
les rancoeurs du match à lui tout seul
entre limoges et châteauroux drôle a le
coeur de la prendre vis ma vie je suis
mort mais joe walcott café ou en plus il
est très bon ça fait qu'une petite
terreur qu'on est là il ya un abri donc
on est bien le bon courage à tous les
gars vous êtes appuyé à l'heure vous
êtes tous devant 11h30
10h15 cette affaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien c'est peut-être que tu as
aujourd'hui je suis beau gaza en plus je
me suis coupé les cheveux
c'est vrai mais qui je trouve dans l'eau
mais que se passe-t-il
la suisse la suède arrive à paella que
paris s'il absolument monsieur
absolument ça va bah ouais on va essayer
de rentrer chez one plus voyagé j'ai
passé un badge adjectif gens du staff
pas vous dites mais les gars alors n'a
qu'un numéro un le numéro deux et numéro
deux numéros de wayne numéro 3 ra
arriver là le numéro 3 mais nous avons
de minéraux 3 devant le miroir
nous avons le numéro 3 le numéro 4 à
tous et faire un numéro sept numéros de
fax numéro 6 numéro 9 est pourquoi je
crois d'escalier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais faire un petit tour du pop up
store regarder devant l'entrée comme ça
vous avez tout va voir comment ça
s'articule la kiss salut ça va on est
pas mal là on est pas mal mais pas alors
le principe c'est qu'on n'arrive juste
la petite histoire petit miser toutes
les infos produits les cils et ça c'est
cool
en fait à une timeline avec les dates
des modèles différents modèles sont
exposés aussi fait des croquis originaux
garder ce boulot c'est juste
impressionnant comme il faut être
capable de faire ça comme ça je trouve
ça hyper choix tu es là vous avez des
des coqs qui ont été enfin db tôt en
tout cas de smartphones qui ont été
design et est en fait vous avez le boss
qui vient dans une grande pièce et
regard tout moment je le sens à sa est
en gros tout le reste rien voyez ça ça
restera à l'idée en tout cas de ba2
proto d'idées mais voilà ça irait plus
loin on arrive ici tu dans l'espace ou
bien on va découvrir les produits pour
ceux qui le connaissent pas encore bien
les spécialistes en plus c'est bien on a
des petites méduses qui sont là alors
beau jeu testé le smartphone autofocus
déjà champions venus écouter leur
connaît vachement bien le visage des
ministres qu'il faut qu'elle surveille
ça c'est le problème des médias
reconnaissance faciale nous aurons là
les petites méduses qui sont juste là on
va ensuite de notre côté comme ça
instaure vous vous en douterez il y a
des caisses vous avez ici donc toute une
partie 20 15 c'est pop up store là c'est
la partie d'émile donc là vous avez les
spécialistes gaming ils font la queue
bon jouer si et ça et surtout ce truc
est vachement cool c'est que vous avez
derrière moi un mur de coqs pas de
mauvais jeux de mots qui est juste là et
toutes les personnes qui vont jouer
chacune pourra prendre cinq coques
personnalisées
parce que vous avez vraiment chaque
coque du coup complètement unique pour
votre modèle petite partie photo pour le
côté souvenir toucher les composants
votre photo et on arrive ensuite ici à
la partie en boxing où nous on est sous
des éclairages titres mandarine
on va pouvoir bronzer toute la journée
il y en n b you man qui est de la partie
autant dire que là franchement ça
déchire
[Musique]
elle te fait aller beaucoup plus vite la
douane plus fou c'est leur site avec
tant d'hommes et a vu les escales et
qu'on a monté mais qu à bgv ouais on y
est toujours
qu'est-ce que tu après j'ai le one plus
pro en 12 giga de ram way version bleu
donc la version 4
je suis au top du top mais moi je suis
trop de temps s'écoule et arrive à coeur
du bourg
je suis arrivé à 9h30
on a été dans la troisième vague à
rentrer et
on a vu le petit musée et où la jouer
gameloft a 29 qui est vraiment vraiment
cool ouais et cet écran il est juste
bon ça va merci david m ouais trop bien
on sera bientôt à bientôt
je récupère la photo c'est bon quoi
exactement
kooza d'or mais moi aussi je t'adore
chaque côté me demande si l'on prend un
peu surestimé le nombre de pizzas bon je
crois que c'était une part faire ça
c'est ce qu'elle s'était grèce des
pizzas par personne il ya deux ans j'ai
commencé ce que j'ai entendu et il reste
combien la bombe à écouter ça tombe bien
j'avais faim tu veux boire aussi parce
que la liesse qui font tout ça c'est de
mai c'est la boisson énergétique ça ça
veut dire que si je vois tous un joueur
comme moi le résumé c'est pas assez
d'énergie de mots déjà comme je suis
spitz une fille du café tu me files ça
tu me tues à barr garde le café et la
halle energy drink et la santé c'est bon
allez au revoir monsieur re à qui
j'allais de ma chaîne de vidéo merci
beaucoup d'être tous trompé dans mon
triste et c'est très sexy ou fait venu
c'est vraiment c'est très très fier de
vous voir en vrai de pouvoir vous
touchez pas du tout je sais pas c'est
loupé
[Musique]
la vie dure au ps que tu vas y arriver
allez c'est ça que tu veux faire
[Musique]
il
epic alors je te trouve au top comme ça
ça passe bien oui on est plus tabou ta
vie non ça va merci marais salants
c'était très bien moi lbo c'est donc pas
le pouvoir
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi qu'est ce
qui vous a plu la pizza ouais ben bella
la plus pure de pizza de gaulle alors de
tous les smartphones qui avait
aujourd'hui je crois que j'ai préféré le
one tu sais trop rien
pas cela le set cros plutôt sur le web
je prononce toujours mal je suis en
remplacer van tu veux tu peux voir que
ces ragots
c'est ça la jeunesse c'est la jeunesse
je voulais sincères félicitations